it's it's funny because me and connor
were talking about like our perfect
vacation
right and like our perfect vacation
which we were like we were hoping to do
some time after covid allowed us
was just to like fly to korea spend an
entire day
in like a gaming cafe
the only problem with that is i have to
play legally
it's good it's good because to me like
the perfect vacation is just shutting
off and like
yeah i miss being able to waste all day
playing games and what better way to do
it than in korea and a gaming cafe yeah
with like where you can get
food all that kind of [ __ ] delivered to
your table
sounds amazing i don't know because yeah
i really want to i love league and i
like
i'll i'll join you guys but i'll play
morrow yeah you could just come in yeah
yeah yeah
just chill next to us in one of the pc
yeah play pubg i don't know
what do you play on pc i don't know just
go on to [ __ ] or something
i'm just imagining imagine imagining
that but we can also go out and get
[ __ ] korean barbecue
exactly some amazing food and i'm just
like this is just the perfect holiday
[ __ ] travelling you're not seeing things
yeah because i'm
i'm the kind of guy when i go on
vacation i just because i work
so [ __ ] much i the last thing i want
to do is work on my vacation in terms of
like
doing too much [ __ ] like i just want to
eat food drink and relax dude like
just take it easy like i i like beaches
but i mean i normally just
i like like good hotels as well i mean
that's why like whenever i go on a
vacation with aki or i go on a vacation
with like
my friends i usually let them decide
yeah yeah yeah
and i just
we want to just drink cool yeah yeah i'm
very hands off
with my vacation i just if if there's a
schedule i'm like
no this is already a turn off right now
yeah i should love food where are some
places though that we've been thinking
to go once kobit is over i mean we
mentioned korea right
yeah i would like to go to korea to just
just spend is that like at the top of
your bucket list right now i mean right
now because it's just easiest to get to
yeah it's like less than an hour yeah
right yeah and i remember going to
korea like two years ago i think
i've never been it was actually like
seoul was just very much like tokyo just
less busy
um and i just i very much enjoyed the
vibe and also
the esports scene was massive there i
went there for the league of legends
grand finals we both love watching the
legends uh worlds soon yeah that's
that's starting soon but yeah i flew all
the way to korea just to see
fnatic get decimated but the experience
was
[ __ ] fantastic like like the team i
was actually cheering for got [ __ ]
destroyed but just just seeing just
going there and seeing this
massive stadium like the noise that they
made like i've been to a football
match before but i still think the
energy
of this like stadium watching a [ __ ]
video game was like 10 times more
intense
oh yeah yeah i mean like i've seen clips
of sports commentators versus esports
commentators
i love that i love that clip because i'm
just like wow this guy is excited for
that
tensor kill dude there's so many good
clips like that yeah yeah the
commentators get
so hype it's it's great i love it i mean
i totally get it though right dude we
get so [ __ ] hype when we watch it
dude yeah we like stand up but like what
the [ __ ]
i mean we get like that whenever we
watch like insane speedruns
we're just like what's happening
that's the true spectator yeah exactly
yeah super monkey ball speed runs
are the the best thing to watch dude
like the cocaine of speedruns
you get like if you get super drunk and
watch super monkey ball speedruns it's
so funny which is what we did last year
christmas
christmas we just got massively drunk
and watched super monkey ball speeding
it's
so fun because you're like what is
happening how do you practice this
like you're like the next the next you
like you just you're like what the [ __ ]
then the next course starts like what's
he gonna do yeah then he just [ __ ]
flips the whole world and gets it in
across the map you're like what the [ __ ]
it's so good what is it about motion
controls that makes
it so much more impressive she's crazy
man going back to youtube burnout yeah
yeah yeah
where were we on that point i mean is
there anything else we want to talk
about
i wonder um like where are you at right
now with it like
are you do you feel would you say you're
burnt out
numb i was in like um kind of a mini
burnout i feel like i just have artist
block right now i can't think of
anything i'm not
i don't dislike it i love it more than
ever i just can't think of anything
right i think
speaking honestly i am like pretty close
to burnout yeah like it's it's it's like
it's been difficult because
i was already i was already having
trouble keeping up and
a semblance of like a schedule this year
and then trash taste started
and like you think you know because we
take one we take one day off a week to
film this
right which doesn't sound like a lot but
for me
as someone who like values he already
values every day that i do work
it's like it kind of like builds up so
that one that one day a week turns into
like
quite a lot when we're adding like extra
secret projects on top of that and
yeah we have a lot coming in there yeah
i mean obviously yeah
so i i guess for me especially after
trash change started i'm trying to
figure out a good
a new work-life balance that kind of
works with
me doing everything yeah i'm not working
myself to death
or maybe i just might take a break
anytime sometime soon i don't i don't
know yet i'm figured it out
yeah that's the thing right it's about
it's not about
seeing if you can take a break or seeing
like what the balance is because
everyone's balances i feel work really
different
yeah because like for me at least my my
rule of thumb is
at least three days of the week yeah i
try and not do any youtube stuff
yeah so like four days and and also
weekly weekends for me as well
so it's like two days in the weekend and
then one to two days during the week
is just the day where i don't do
anything it's just no work no youtube
work
nothing and then the rest of the four
days i go balls to the walls
yeah and like that's all i do but like
of course it depends on my schedule
right but i feel that like because
before
when i was in like that really really
like deep deep
uh burnout i wasn't going out at all
like i wasn't going to see anybody
having like
a social life is like really important
to not feeling like you're trapped
yeah and i think definitely for me like
ax
and conventions in general were such a
huge like yeah
it's so refreshing that you go to a
convention because that and we just
didn't get that i know
and why i think everything's just been
exasperated right it was awful yeah
because i remember
the last day x that happened so 2019
i distinctly remember the week before i
act i was working so much that i thought
like i was just already like [ __ ]
start crying and like
yeah i'm just like i can't do this and
if that ax hadn't happened
i'd like at that time i don't know what
i would have done because i think it
would have been
way too burnt out because yeah i burned
myself out
so much so that in the anticipation that
i could enjoy this thing
and have the vacation and luckily it was
great i had a [ __ ] great time
yeah um and yeah it's been it's been
weird now because we don't
have any of that and i remember speaking
to emily and i and emily was like when's
the last time you took a vacation before
the
night i won and i was like um
like an actual vacation i think it was
like two or three years
yeah never took a vacation it was just
like maybe a weekend trip
that was like a little getaway for like
one or two days but not like an actual
vacation
it actually been like two three years
plus i do actually don't know yeah
because i never would
yes you don't think about it right no
because conventions were my
i mean conventions work right they were
technically they were 100 work
like you still enjoyed it and it was it
was just something like a nice break
from your routine that's why i enjoy
conventions but i can't really call it a
vacation and it was crazy that i would
go like two three years just didn't even
question if i needed a break like
even christmas like and all the family
holidays and stuff that i would i would
do i would still be doing work
yeah it was crazy well i think that's
why like i've kind of been blessed in
that aspect because
i am really good at scheduling and
getting it on top of my schedule
because i've been able to take short
vacations like whether it be with family
or with friends or just whatever
just very frequently like you know minus
all of the conventions because to me
conventions
on a vacation it's just a different type
of work just just having like a weekend
away helps so much to like
recharge you i think and as well because
my videos have been getting a lot more
ambitious as well recently so i've just
been adding on more work with that
that's the culture
same upload schedule but like three
times the amount of work yeah exactly
exactly
i did uh by the time we were recording
it like a rent-a-boyfriend video
first video was easy it was two hours of
work on my end
of recording work um because there's
loads of other work that went in before
that but
two hours of just reacting to
applications that's easy yeah second
part was hard because
i had to schedule uh 13 people
with different time zones calls uh one
hour calls with these people and then
plan out what i was going to do on each
call
because i did something different for
everyone yeah right one of them i had to
like get a whole bob ross set up
yeah and one of them i had to get all
sculpting stuff
and others just different things for
each one and there's a one-hour each so
just pure call times it was 13 hours
yeah and then on top of that i had to
then [ __ ] micromanage my schedule
which
if you try and schedule time zones oh my
[ __ ] oh yeah
it's not difficult but you feel like
your brain is going to implode yeah
trying to juggle all these time zones
and plot them all out and this is just
for one video yeah
and then on you know back in march i did
the audiobook video
which is like a month of straight work
yeah that was the most
stress i've ever seen i thought i
thought you were gonna burn out there
like i don't know how i didn't because i
was also uploading weekly videos in
between
this behemoth of a video yeah it's crazy
because i had to make the audio book and
make the video i just
i don't know how i did not forget that's
that's that's the double edged sword
isn't it is that like the more you do
youtube and like the moment you're like
yeah the moment you you decide to
venture out into that one ambitious idea
and you make it happen and it's
successful then you start thinking all
right
i did it once yeah yeah i could do it
again yeah but better yeah yeah and then
it just keeps getting
exactly and then it just keeps
escalating and escalating until you
realize
oh [ __ ] i don't have time to make this
video right
and it's either going to suck or i have
to sacrifice
other ideas